this is dr. John Delaney with Ramsey
Network what up hope you're doing good
hope you're staying safe hope you're
being smart and we're back with the one
and only Miss Erica young the smartest
person either of us will ever talk to
today
this is awesome to have you back she is
a engineer a long time ramsey preferred
coach and now we're gonna get into the
good stuff today yeah if you didn't
watch the last two videos make sure you
go watch them we are building to this
very moment right here we left you on a
cliffhanger last time and now it's time
it's good I love talking to people whose
job is talking other people I have a
passion for helpers who help other
people I like to describe stress like a
brick in a backpack all right so we all
carry around bricks in our backpacks
from some of those are from childhood
some of those are from systems some of
those are from any number of places we
got breaks in our backpack and when we
are taking on debt when we are
struggling in our marriage we are
carrying those things and as a coach
your job somebody comes to you with
their backpack and they just drop that
sucker on a table they say help and your
job is to help people take those bricks
out of their backpack and in many ways
to carry those four people and I used to
only think that was for coaches or for
psychologists or for counselors for
lawyers but over the last few months
I've expanded it much bigger husband's
carry the bricks of their wives and
their kids and moms carry the bricks of
their children and their children's
friends and kids carry the bricks of
their friends and so this is this is
something that we can all hear and
listen to the last three or four months
have been heavy for a financial coach
right
and so day after day minute after minute
hour after hour you're taking Xoom call
and zoom call and racing off over here
to have a social or distance
conversation was that right and at the
same time you're a mom your wife your
community member that's a lot sir and so
walk me through what the last few months
have been as you are carrying your
backpack and you're also like yeah I'll
carry yours
your ears and suddenly you got a lot on
air key on his back yeah I actually
thought I had to really dive in and show
up for my community like right away as
soon as all you know we shut down and I
realized that this was going to be here
for a minute I just started sending all
the newsletters and having zoom calls
and having a happy hour with my
community who followed me and got into
action doing things on Sunday never do
that right
the evenings started to be taken and my
husband was like you're busier than ever
it's because I did it to myself first of
all but I wanted to show up and I
started doing that for a couple of weeks
and it was great I got a lot of good
response but I realized that instead of
allowing that backpack that they have to
be theirs that I was taking those bricks
on that I that I thought that was my
responsibility because of the role that
I play and you know I I would challenge
it to say I want to help you figure out
how to take yours off like leave it at
the feet of Jesus and not me take it on
right because I wanted to you know be
present and help and give resources and
all of that which is good
but I didn't make space for you know me
to do a whole lot of processing either
so helpers are often two things one
folks who become helpers coaches yeah
are often those folks in their homes in
their communities that people rely on
all the time anyway yeah right my guess
is you can't make it out of church
without somebody being like hey while
you're here you got a second hey my son
hang town my daughter-in-law needs a
write and that's just kind of your life
right probably sitting in a restaurant
and someone stops and says hey I need to
talk to you about it like that's just
kind of the nature of who helpers are
that find their way into helping
profession right the second thing is is
the the underbelly of the helping
professions is that it makes me feel
good I get some value out of this and
the temptation for helpers is to get
their identity or their validation or
their clicks that word
this from help somebody else I have
somebody else right
how you managing that it's a lot I mean
it's overwhelming it's exhausting let me
back out is that true in your world
you're accountable and that it feels
good and you gotta fight yourself
I enjoy it I like I'm showing up for
people I love being that encouraged er I
mean I come from it were you that way as
a kid absolutely I was a cheerleader
okay all right it goes way back it goes
way back I love that I love putting a
smile on someone else's face but
sometimes your cheeks are hurting right
like I mean there are ramifications to
that and oh and there it's their smile
is that the expense of your smile right
well yeah and and then when my husband
says what do you have left for us that's
real talk like he said that for me a
couple times a night and I'm like okay
what does that mean because if I'm
giving to everybody else all the time
and I don't have anything from my family
or I'm worn out and I just want to veg
out in front of the TV you know perform
numbing behaviors scrolling and all the
things then am i showing up enough for
those that really matter or for myself
even right and so just that has to
become a part of the self-care for sure
so how she went there so that's
preventable so it's been my experience
that particularly brilliant
serving professional women who are also
moms who are also yeah wives they find
themselves in a particularly messy
situation because there is never an off
switch sure there's never like whether
it's culturally or whether it is just
expectations that people put on
themselves or that others assume they're
gonna put on themselves there is no off
switch right right and so you get done
taking care of your professional world
and now you've got the expectation to
take care of all this world - right and
this idea of taking care of you becomes
the last priority that just gets rolled
over to tomorrow that thing on our list
the list that we just Circle and we'll
do it tomorrow right right what are
signals for yourself that you've left
Erica Young out of the equation
yes well I crashed and burned one day
okay I mean honestly I had there was a
Thursday a specific Thursday where I was
nippy with my family I was not friendly
with my dog he was just trying to help
right and and I was not you know
president I didn't want to cook I didn't
want to you know show up I mean I wanted
to hide in my basement and just do
nothing in the dark and and when I you
know had that moment and there were
tears and there were you know just this
whole I mean I just felt that anxiety
that stressed that you know all of that
coming up and I'm like this is too much
I mean it was a lot and and I realized I
was tired I wasn't sleeping enough I
wasn't eating well I was the corona
snacks got me right my workouts weren't
effective or non-existent so several
days I was staying up late and that's
not good for me I'm not an evening
nighttime person and so when a lot of
those things began to get out of whack I
mean it just hit me that day the best
thing that you know I could say is you
know I reached out to my community I
mean I just I told my family I need a
minute okay I mean I just I'm sorry
I'm nippy I get it I heard that please
leave me alone right now I asked for it
and then I asked you know some friends
of mine hey you know are you guys
experienced in this and someone asked me
are you working out and like yeah but
I'm going through the motions right and
it's not it's not producing anything for
me and so I switched it up you know I
switched it up and did something
different and got some fresh air and you
know did some things that I don't
normally do in order to really see it
from a different perspective and and
have some self-care that might not have
been normal for me it is like you're a
rare person that has the self awareness
enough to know to look at their loved
ones and say hang on a second I'm not
gonna be my best me I need to go step
away for a second and that you've got
people who love you that honored that
space right is that an easy thing for
you to do is that a hard thing for you
to do well I had to recognize it first
okay right and did you recognize it cuz
somebody called you on it or did you
know
yeah okay my teenager was like mom's a
little like you know yeah she just rare
but the common common thing for a parent
to do when a kid calls him out is to be
like well if you would just she didn't
do that I didn't I you know I value I
actually honestly say that when my kids
say something I really have to listen
cuz I'm not perfect I have never been a
parent of a 20 year old right so clearly
I don't know everything about being the
parent of a 20 year old so when when
they say hey mom was a little did you
hear that and she didn't know I heard
her you know I heard her like in the
course of the day and I was like oh here
we go
let me just give myself together because
I'm lashing out I'm not being productive
in my my role right here it's not
working so you said a couple of things
that differentiates you from most people
I work with and I meet with you were
faced with a set of challenges that you
wanted to meet to make that lift you up
right and in doing so you ended up
carrying a lot of burden and a lot of
heaviness in your home and in yourself I
love this picture of like I want to go
sit in the dark in my basement which is
a great metaphor for depression right
that's what that is right and if you
don't have a dark basement you go there
anyway whether that's Tiger king again
or whether that's scrolling all right we
all have our own dark basements right
but you have a community around you that
you allow to speak into your life yeah
you've got a series of actions whether
it's working out whether that is calling
people that you know heal you and number
three you went to a mirror first like
what am i bringing to this that's
probably getting out of whack how did
you get there
that's a hard place for most grown-ups
to be get to the place where I can
recognize that like if I look around
that folks in the pandemic the world's
on fire all those crazy stuff the last
place people are going is to the mirror
and saying what am i contributing to the
negativity yeah true well the thing is
is how if I can't show up you know the
way I want to show up so that I can
bring my best self to the world then I
have to look inward I
I have to I have to do that because you
know it's gonna take more energy to
climb over and to help other people if
I'm not in the right headspace if I'm
not in the right you know me version
right and so the best part is so for me
did you ever have moments when you
weren't able to show up that showed you
that oh for sure yeah we we we probably
can have those moments every day right
we can we can probably have those every
week where you know something's off let
me reset let me go back let me go look
in the mirror who are you really trying
to be let me go you know read that
scripture again let me you know get some
good content into me so that I can be
much show up the best way possible and
and so there are we we can feel that and
sometimes I feel it with clients yeah
sometimes I'm there with clients I'm
like oh this doesn't feel right are you
okay and are we okay and and we have to
do that reset because if they're arguing
for instance on the customs something
went amiss to where we're to the point
where we're actually arguing right now
or they're arguing between them and so
let's figure out where did that come
from
what's behind that because there's more
to that story and so I want to make
certain that we re-engage in the way we
need to re-engage so I have to do that
internally first and that's a that's a
way of showing that you bring grace and
dignity to a conversation and someone
comes at you full you're able to you're
able to feel somebody coming at you they
start to argue with your math or but I
can't do this or you don't understand or
whatever the excuse is right and you are
confident enough in yourself in your
spirituality and your relationships to
know that's not about me yes you're not
coming to me you're coming at your past
self you're coming at your shame you're
coming at your bad decisions and my job
is to help shoulder some of that but to
walk with you yes well one of the
biggest things that I've learned in
coaching this is huge I learned this
years and years ago in training actually
a gentleman Russ Carroll was one
of our trainers in you know our coach
training and he said you have to wash
your hands between clients and so I
visualized myself washing my hands of
the drama the stress like I have to give
my nuggets I have to give my
encouragement I can't be attached to
their outcomes I have to give them the
tools the resources the ideas the hope
the inspiration of it and then wash my
hands because they've got to take the
action yes they have to take the action
if I take it on then I'm carrying their
backpack yeah and so I just envisioned
myself washing my hands between the
clients because then that way I can move
on and be fully present for that next
person yes yeah and I would recommend
that moms and dads do that oh yes
wash your hands of work before you get
home and engage your husband or wife if
you have a hard conversation with one of
your kids wash your hands before you go
engage with your other kids right if you
just kicked the dog wash your hands
before you go talk to the mailman or
you're driving home and somebody from
work calls essays that things I'm not
gonna get dental tomorrow right as you
pull in and your heart rate gets up wash
your hands before you go say hey family
right don't bring that stuff home and
it's not faking it that's not even it
really is just not taking on whatever
that previous moment was don't make it
internal to you it you can't own it it's
just something we say on this show all
the time is I get to choose who hurts my
feelings yes I get to choose who takes
away my dignity and respect and I get to
choose how I treat people that's a
choice mm-hmm it is
and I choose living those things in
action oh what a gift thank you so much
my head's blown my heart's full so thank
you for being here tell everybody where
they can find you all of the Internet's
yes you can find me at tailor-made
budgets calm and on LinkedIn Erica young
as well as Instagram tailor-made budgets
I will follow her as soon as this is
over you should too don't forget to
subscribe to the show follow me at John
Delaney or follow her if you have to
fall somebody day photo showed me
this is ridiculous it's so great thank
you for being here take care this is dr.
John Delaney Ramsey network be nigh be
nice be more kind doc to you soon